at his flat in Birmingham Ollie Bain is
constantly trying to save electricity
the prepayment meter in the kitchen
tells him how much money is left since
the price went up last year it's become
a daily battle
it's gone up quite a lot with the
heating if it goes below minus
then I will put it on I probably say
about
15-20 minutes just to warm the room up
just a little bit I don't cook as much
on the cooker anymore because everything
in my flat is electric there's no gas
and um I've noticed a really big
difference when it comes to the cooker
um what do you eat instead I um I am
from cold baked beans energy costs more
on prepayment meters but increasingly
people are being forced by energy
companies to use them after struggling
to keep up with bills in some cases
Smart Meters have been switched to
prepayment meters remotely well in other
cases teams with court warrants have
been sent to people's homes to forcibly
make the change now the business
secretary has written to energy
suppliers demanding that they stop the
practice and asking them to reveal how
many warrants they're getting so he can
name and shame the worst Defenders
citizens advice estimates around 600 000
people in Great Britain were forced onto
a prepayment meeting last year while 3.2
million people ran out of credit because
they couldn't afford to top up and money
savings expert found that the average
yearly cost of the cheapest prepayment
deal was around 44 pounds more than the
cheapest standard deal we're seeing a
growing number of people freezing to
death in their own homes campaigners say
the government needs to go further and
ban forced prepayment meters it's
horrendous the amount of effort energy
company is going to to force people to
pay more money prepayment meters cost
more money for people to actually use
and the vulnerable and the elderly and
disabled who are struggling to pay and
aren't aren't working are being forced
people are forcing themselves into their
homes to install these meters the chief
executive of energy UK which represents
energy companies said Supply buyers are
already required to have exhausted all
other options before installing a
prepayment meter by warrant only after
repeated unsuccessful attempts to
contact the customer to discuss
repayment options and offer support but
as Millions struggle through the cold
this winter many more face difficulty
with further price Rises on the horizon
in Spring Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham